[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
at the end of every year crosstalk
answers some of your many questions not
surprisingly many of your questions
concern politics the current
international situation and whether we
should trust legacy media we'll do our
best to answer as many questions as we
can
[Music]
crosstalking q a i'm joined by my guest
glenn diesen in oslo he is professor at
the university south eastern norway as
well as author of the book break power
politics in the fourth industrial
revolution and in plymouth we have
patrick henningson he's the editor and
founder of 21st centurywire.com all
right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump anytime
you want i got a lot of questions let's
see if we can get through as many as
possible here the first question is let
me go to glenn first
what are the chances of an armed
conflict involving russia and nato in
the new year thoughts
well i think it's uh unlikely but it's
becoming increasingly likely uh
i
the they are the good news is that
they're recognizing the key difficulties
in
we have in europe and the main conflict
is effectively what is the european
security security architecture for the
russians they're demanding it has to be
based on all our pan-european security
agreements which suggest indivisible
security so you know nato for example
one side can't expand their security at
the expense of russia while the nato is
arguing uh european security should be
based on the principle of
nato's freedom to expand
so so this is the main
main main conflict but at least at least
they're having discussions about this
which is uh something nato didn't even
want to do in the past but that being
said um
nato's also said that well russia has
pointed out that it will intervene in
ukraine if
ukraine attacks donbass or if there is
if nato is expanding or even you know
u.s troops starting to
move into ukraine
however that being said uh
if russia intervenes the americans have
made it clear they're not going to
respond and intervene on on the other
side so
it seems that the work can be avoided
but that being said there's always this
risk of miscalculation so uh effectively
the problem is everyone wants to have a
peace agreement but uh
this there doesn't seem to be any room
for compromise and in the absence of
peace agreement it appears that war
might become the only alternative you
know patrick the the interesting time i
mean the fact that they're talking okay
the russians have said that nato has
been talking like this for 20 years okay
the russians want it in writing i mean
this is something new it is a bit of a
departure from their usual procedures
here i think that's what it is most
importantly talk is talk but we want it
in writing and we want it to be public
and transparent go ahead patrick
i think
russia's in a very strong
diplomatic position because it's made
its intentions well known it's setting
the pace uh especially by uh its recent
move in december uh with issuing its
sort of demands against nato but the
thing that worries me is you have a very
weak president in the white house and
mind you this
if there is anything uh in terms of
aggression from the nato side or
anything they would like to provoke it's
always on the table it's just a question
of when it's most politically
opportuned to do so and if this
administration is desperate in
washington they might push the button on
something i'm not sure what that
something would be in order to resurrect
its flailing uh poll numbers this has
happened many times throughout history
so it's not anything that we should be
surprised about so
but i don't think there's a lot that
nato can do
other than provocations and skirmishes
as we've seen uh in recent years uh with
the kurt straits and so forth but what
what really worries me is the potential
for
uh a misunderstanding or a false flag or
a another mh17 type event in which case
the west would automatically blame
russia and then that would most
certainly trigger a new round of
sanctions and the point of that is is
the bigger picture here is about what
the global agenda is or what the agenda
for europe is and it's to not allow the
minx accords uh to be realized and that
creates that sanctions uh labor that
europe and the in the west will continue
to hold uh over russia so and this is
part of a bigger agenda which is to
vulcanize deglobalize and decarbonize
uh europe so i think that's the bigger
picture in the background and what we're
seeing on the on the military skirmish
front or the provocation front is really
just an excuse uh for the the west and
the dominant interests in the west to
exact this new uh globalized or
anti-anti-globalized or globalist agenda
whichever way you want to frame it so um
but it is a very dangerous
uh potentially dangerous situation
hopefully could avoid a full-scale
conflict well we'll certainly be keeping
an eye on it as we always have uh let's
go to our next question here glenn i
don't know if this is exactly up your
alley but it's an interesting question
what is worse corporatism in oligarchy
or neoliberal wokism that's a fantastic
question i think we could do a series of
programs on it go ahead
uh it's a good question i'm not sure if
they're mutually exclusive though i mean
okay uh a lot of this new liberal
walkism uh kind of goes a bit hand in
hand with
the corporatism again i think that one
of the key problems in
with with the neoliberal economics and
the oligarchy that followed is
that
that the political system hasn't been
able to function as it should so again
the political left can't redistribute
wealth
political right comfort
protect or redistribute
protect
distinctive communities countries
produce its own culture all this all
this regular
these issues which he would usually have
been pursuing now i think that
in the absence of
any of the political parties either
left or right being able to address the
main economic problems and
the main problems are economic i think
it's more appealing to
to go into a culture war so yeah why why
do i talk about the economic inequality
becoming unsustainable where they can
talk about you know transgender toilets
and
uh you know men competing as women in
sports all this uh uh nonsense so i
think uh
um yeah not necessarily mutual mutually
exclusive but if i would pick i guess
the neoliberal walking them has
it has a greater challenge simply
because
it uh yeah deconstructs some of the most
basic uh
foundations of society so
yeah okay patrick the same question to
you i mean i i tend to agree with glenn
here i mean both are bad then it's like
choosing one over the other go ahead you
give it a shot
well i would have answered it pretty
much the same as glenn did regarding
that they're not mutually uh exclusive
but the thing to point out which i think
is really interesting as is the west has
used uh wokism or used the culture wars
to break down
uh other countries and to soften them up
internally
and to undermine traditional
values and the sort of traditional or
conservative or cohesive uh elements of
a society certainly the the western
media and the activist global activist
community and the ava's network and so
forth have done this to russia
with regards to using lgbt issues
they've done this to syria as well so if
you look at the target nations iran as
well so you look at the target nations
that are on the west's regime change
list
they've used this but this is a bit of a
genie that has been let out of the
bottle and threatens to really destroy
some of these countries or politically
destabilize them from inside certainly
we're seeing this in the united states
and it threatens really to eviscerate uh
the current form of the democratic party
uh as well they cannot handle
it's gotten out of control so maybe
maybe we're seeing the the end of the
arc of of this and it might be turning
in another direction certainly it's an
existential crisis for the democratic
party yeah to allow this radical wing to
take over yeah when these people are in
a circular firing squad just let them
finish it off themselves okay let's
rapidly go to the next question here
this is probably this was the most
popular question sent to me i'm i'm a
little disappointed but i'm going to
give it to you guys anyway
do you think trump will run in 2024 and
if you do do you think it's a good idea
glenn
well
he has suggested that he might run
but also hillary clinton has indicated
she might run as well so we might get a
repeat of
um however i'm not quite sure if he will
run yet it's still
a while into the future and
i guess it would depend on the mood of
the country so
like he's argued in 2016 he wouldn't run
if he didn't think he could win and so i
think it depends on the support he has
from both the political party and
from the voters now
i don't i don't think necessarily that
he should run simply because i think
what the united states needs the most
now
is uh to
bridge this huge polarization within the
united states which is
getting out of control
where the perceived the political
opposition effectively to be an enemy
this is something you have to address so
you need perhaps a less polarizing
uh figure and you know whether you like
or hate donald trump uh
i guess what can objectively say is
quite polarizing and i think that's a
bit of a dangerous path to take for the
united states
i think the second main challenge for
the united states is it needs to adapt
to the new world order that is it
effectively been running the past 30
years on the ideal of a liberal hegemony
where the us would
rule the world under its own principles
and i think
this has come to an end and there has to
be some
way of transitioning away from this
now i
think uh
donald trump does not necessarily
rejected u.s global hegemony um he
simply believed that uh you know funding
subsidizing allies were too costly and
he rather uh running with this on his
own however he did reject the liberal
hegemony part so i think from that
perspective uh he's his main
value i guess to to the us has been
uh that he's a transitional figure so i
think that uh a lot of new voices have
come up in the united states since he
became president
where they're
contesting the whole idea of liberal
hegemony both on political right and
political left
but
for him the person to
uh to run himself i think it would be
uh
we would might exacerbate a lot of the
problems uh of the united states simply
because it seems half the country
believe he planned a terrorist attack on
the capitol and you know he's an agent
of russia i think it's very difficult
for him to
uh yeah to to lead such a divided
country
in any case if it was a rematch with hrc
it would be a whole lot of theater but
it wouldn't solve anything all right
gentlemen i'm going to jump in here
we're going to go to a hard break and
after that hard break we'll continue our
discussion on this year's q a stay with
rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
to remind you we're discussing this
year's q a
[Music]
okay let's go uh back to patrick here
patrick you want to answer should trump
come back in 2024 are your thoughts go
ahead
um
i think on some level it's it's
inevitable if you take the temperature
of uh half the country right now in the
us certainly all the signals are there
if you're watching uh media and so forth
but you know you have to consider a
couple of extenuating circumstances the
first being his age
i don't think it's a major problem
compared to joe biden it would be a
second term so he's going into a second
term rather than his first term as
opposed to biden but the trump agenda is
already kind of
baked in to the republican party so in
that sense it wouldn't be i don't think
there would be any surprises uh with the
trump presidency in the second term um
so i think it on that
side it's good but then if you want to
bring in new blood it would most likely
come via a vice president's
appointee on the ticket so that right
now looks like it would be ron desantis
that would be an easy handover for the
republican party
after trump would finish a second term
and mike pompeo is going to run for
president uh in in the republican
primary ted cruz i'm sure marco rubio
and rand paul tom cotton will also be in
there as well but there's such a
polarized swing right now it's swung so
far
into one direction in just the first
year the biden administration and you'll
see the midterms bear bear out a result
probably in favor of the republicans and
the house and senate so there's going to
be a shift in politics the question is
is that shift going to want to continue
with donald trump or to bring in
somebody
younger and more dynamic perhaps it has
maybe a longer tail future in politics
we shall see but it looks to me it looks
like he is going to run
so we'll but who knows what will happen
between now and i'm sure on this program
we'll revisit that issue a number of
times here let's keep with political
personalities here uh many viewers the
uh the question
who's more of a failure joe biden or
boris johnson question to you glenn
uh well it's difficult to compare the
two leaders i guess they are they're
ruling their difference
but they do have a lot in common their
failures but that's that's enough don't
you thank god
well i'm inclined to say joe biden
simply because he has a more challenging
task ahead i mean the
like i mentioned before the us will have
to adapt from this unipolar area to
the multiple order which is already here
which is having
immense difficulties in terms of doing
furthermore the us
appears to have much greater
challenges in terms of the financial and
economic crisis the country is moving
into so the u.s needs a lot of it has a
lot of painful reforms it needs to carry
through to restore fiscal responsibility
however the u.s has less room for
maneuver because it also has this you
know global empire it's carrying on its
shoulder so uh
so it has less ability to
uh maneuver to
uh to to restore a lot of this or fix a
lot of these weaknesses so i think
the failings of joe biden has been
more
yet
detrimental while the failings of
um
well well the feelings of of boris
johnson has less
impact i guess
furthermore one could also point out
what we just discussed that u.s society
is so profoundly
divided
again biden
you can also see that he i would argue
he failed on this aspect i mean he ran
on that day of pursuing unity but from
the beginning it became obvious that
unity would require the other side so
the republicans to repent and align
themselves behind this divisive policies
so uh and again this is the problem when
uh when the political opposition is
deemed to be an enemy and there's not
really any more room for compromise
uh
so i think that these are all key
problems and also he he didn't actually
do any of his foreign policy objectives
either he was going to re go back to the
nuclear deal with iran he hasn't done
that he was going to improve relations
with china
he's pretty much followed the trump
policies there as well
and um also
yeah russia has not been able to improve
many of the relation with with that
relationship either so i think um yeah
across the board he's um
he's failed
yeah well patrick same thing so you know
let's go brandon or bojo which one's
worse go ahead
this is a really difficult question to
answer but it's actually quite a
profound question because there is there
is a kind of an answer in there these
are both
these were both gimmick leaders they
both effectively ran on a gimmick
joe biden ran on i'm anyone but donald
trump and managed to garner uh quite a
few uh votes uh just on that basis and
arguably that would have been his a
margin albeit slim considering the other
extenuating electoral challenges and so
forth but boris johnson ran on the
gimmick of brexit and a lot of people
wouldn't realize that just months before
the referendum in 2016. boris johnson
was a committed europhile he had been
his whole career and all of a sudden he
became mr brexit it was a bit of a
marketing sensation politically so
that's how he got his mandate and right
now the uh the people the remainers are
very disenchanted
with boris johnson it really has to do
with the kind of draconian policies uh
around covid and around
vaccine mandates and so forth he's
really just basically hemorrhaged a lot
of this uh support he had and
the miracle of getting the northern
working class to vote for a tory uh
leader and he had trounced in with this
massive mandate that's all but gone now
so in a way uh they're both similar in
that they both ran on a gimmick and in
in some ways
uh well especially biden he was already
a failure before he was even sworn into
office because of the circumstances in
which he was
elected
on many different levels and boris
johnson uh again that uh
it's basically he's spent his political
capital now so but overall i would say
um i would say on some level boris
johnson is is a bigger uh failure
because of this sort of paper mandate
that's now been shredded yeah yeah
i don't think either one of them have
much of a future here let's go to our
next question here um viewers asked i'll
go to glenn here is macron capable of
leading the eu with the departure of
frau merkel go ahead
um i would say no
i can definitely see why he believes he
can take over leadership
because you know germany is running into
some economic difficulties now and its
own political problems uh with the
departure of markel macron also
has certain ideas in terms of you know
creating an eu army which would make
france the
obvious leader within the eu by having a
more militarized eu
however the problem is always that
macron wants to be a leader but nobody
really wants to follow him so i think
that his policies are more focused on
french leadership within the u.s opposed
to a clear vision of how the eu as a
whole can regain its relevance in the
world so uh
for example i'm not seeing any
great ideas or at least a great idea
able to push forward in terms of
establishing greater technological
sovereignty and competitiveness within
the eu
also
the foreign policy i mean he's been
making suggestions perhaps the eu should
start to patch things up with russia but
it
is never able to move anywhere and again
i think this is the main
difficulty the main problem because it's
not able to give any clear benefits for
for the eu
only the last case now
with this northern uh
with north stream too for example it's
uh uh
allowing uh well the u.s as well as
europeans to to
to obstruct this pipeline simply
convincing the russians that they should
shift their gas to asia so as a
consequence eu industries will not be
competitive against asians in the future
so you you don't you don't have any i
don't see him being able to
make the eu relevant by doing what's
needed to be done so
uh
i i don't i don't see it but uh
um again there's a lack of alternatives
at this point though yeah that's the eu
does that all of the time no
alternatives and i think that's by
design unfortunately patrick your
thoughts here because macron is actually
and i've never been a big fan of the the
french president he has matured in
office he is he's a lot more articulate
and uh and and willing to take some uh
chances here and plus he's up for
re-election in the spring here um so i
mean
maybe it's not the right question is
france able to do it instead of macron i
don't know what are your thoughts
uh just looking at the internal domestic
political situation in france uh that's
gonna it looks like a tall order for a
lot of reasons the frexit movement in
france is also very strong arguably as
strong or stronger than any other
european country so there is a lot of
disenchantment with brussels not only
that i would say his popularity now you
have
not just disapproval you probably have
uh by anyone's estimation you know
upwards of 40 percent of the french
public that
strongly dislike emmanuel macron
because of the recent policies and again
it goes back to
basic freedom uh liberte fraternity
egalite there's a lot of french citizens
that do not believe that macron holds
those essential republic french
republican values that's how
disconnected he is with a large part and
important parts segments of the french
population so if you don't have the
support at home
one says how can you lead the european
union whereas angela merkel didn't have
that level of disdain in germany for her
during her tenure at the time
so i think that's a difficult one
for emmanuel macron he was elected as a
technocrat he is a goldman sachs type
candidate he's a mar a young mario
draghi or mario monty type that's uh
what the people who backed him they
envisioned that he would play that role
so we'll see uh i but i don't see him in
terms of populism having the sort of
appeal anymore
then he barely got elected
on the first round i think he's going to
run into problems he might squeak by in
the next election but he doesn't have
the mandate i think that's required to
say that he's really going to be a
strong leader for europe well let's
finish up on mccrone with glenn i mean
what's really interesting is that he's
having to have to grapple with his
re-election is to appeal to the populist
i mean it's really quite amazing that
this is that's gonna make that that's
the tiebreaker in all of this here the
left is completely collapsed and now
it's who's gonna be able to appeal to uh
the uh the populist right and you know
macron wasn't designed to do that kind
of thing your thoughts right before we
end the program go ahead glenn
well i agree i think the french have
lost some of their appetite for the eu
so for him to position himself as the
champion of the eu
while at the same time winning over the
french population
it would require a lot of
paradoxical stances and
a lot of dishonesty and i think
the french have caught up to that as
well so
i yeah i don't think i i don't see it
happening i think you wouldn't even have
a hard time struggling to remain the
leader of
france which putting the leader of the
eu amid making it much more difficult
yeah well that means we have a whole lot
more to talk about in the new year
gentlemen i wish you both a happy new
year that's all the time we have many
thanks to my guests in oslo in plymouth
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at rt see you next time and
remember crosstalk rules
[Music]
you